today and my first class I'd like to
discuss playing with the two bishops in
the middle game and some plans ideas
there's actually a lot of flexibility
without bishops in the middle game so
it's not not something concrete
necessarily so I would like it to be
pretty interactive class discussing
ideas and getting a feel for what you
can and can't do generally in a in a
mental game and this will be like from
the perspective of having two bishops in
any given type of position I've used a
couple of my games I brought a few
positions a couple my games and also
another game and I'm going to start off
here looking at a game I had earlier
this year in Iceland that I like one of
my favorite places to play chess in and
I'm going to pretty much fast forward a
little bit to the the male game I will
briefly comment on the opening just like
via the Berlin defense I decline it with
d3 and we have a fairly symmetrical
structure those who play you 45 probably
get positions where you're just very
similar-looking to this you both
developed pretty slowly c3 and now this
is already kind of like where things
start up one plays Bishop g4 I think
we've all done moves like this and blitz
and sometimes our classical it's already
almost like a bit of a slight inaccuracy
that's only because of the consequences
of yeah developing the bishop that farts
because I will achieve the two bishops
so Bishop g4 normally especially I have
a net on d2 that's not really a threat
Bishop g4 there's no pin or anything
really like a strong when my Queen can
move there's none of that so I did Ricky
one but h3 kind of each three is also
completely fine to force blacks to
develop the bishop and it's not a
weakness for me I did Ricky 197 and my
whole plan is is to crawl that bishop in
so he plays Bishop h5 otherwise I was
d4 I don't think either of us are in
theory it's just you know this is a
Spanish so it's mainly an opening based
on ideas but Bishop h5 and yeah it's one
of those cases again I wouldn't know one
necessarily I've developed a Bishop to
g4 in the first place for the sake of
development I would probably you know do
some other things but bishops bishops
get stronger as the game goes on and
more pawn to get trade off so I'm not
relative I would have put it so
ambitiously over over our notes on h5
and now net f1 c6 any move can be played
but the visual NH 5 is going to be
corralled almost no matter what with the
sequence of Knight g3 Knight age 4 and
then I'm going to one side G but base my
play on the two bishops so no matter
what you did c6
can't really stop it the bish yeah you
pretty much can't stop it there's always
Knight h4 if you go Bishop g6 right now
so c6 Bishop a4 Bishop d6 and no sense
of danger here not really worried about
giving up the two bishops which
sometimes it is the case but usually
usually not the case especially
especially in a structure like this
where it's not a closed position it's
not necessary nope in position but
there's flexible and it can turn into an
open position so the bishops can be
really valuable so I don't I do Bishop
g5 first 93 would have been totally fine
to win the bishop pair which is really
what was in my mind like but this wasn't
a nice remove order to do it Bishop g5
because I can go an edge e3 next move
anyways but I also yeah it's it's a move
order thing but we go in 97 93 Bishop
every Queen f3 and this is the start of
the middle game with two bishops
but that's how we got there so I don't
like it because he gave me the two
[ __ ] by putting his Bishop to g4 I
why that's the move that he probably
should have done but it's still totally
a game and and now and now we have where
things begin how's the position well
it's fairly symmetrical it's set for
that factor I just mentioned about you
know which side has which pieces and
when you have the two bishops
a lot of general principles
apply it's nice not to have your pawns
flexible like this each 3d 3 C 3 not
really any targets for black the ships
get stronger as the games go on is more
pawns you trade in most of the time and
they do well without any permanent
weaknesses or things like that so my
bishops are not tied down to anything
the position anything can happen so it's
a lot of possibilities here
and that usually bodes well for them
when they're not passive they don't have
to defend an isolated pawn they don't
have to help support a piece here the
bishops have kind of like free control
and I'm going to base my game around
that so the first move is 95 because the
black to move without a doubt I play
Bishop c2 there's no way I'm going to
play Bishop d3 and give up give up my
biggest asset 96 is played so attacking
my second Bishop Knight a5 was a threat
potentially Oh Bishop d2 but I have to
think much of these moves
no not even 5 seconds probably I'm not
giving up those bishops I'm not trading
on e7 these are these are these are good
and the bishops are good and they don't
need to be aggressively placed to have a
diagonal they don't need to be on g5
they could be on d2 and still okay right
now this might not look like a fantastic
diagonal but it's almost the same as if
it was on g5 I don't want to get rid of
them that's why I'm putting there there
so it looks like now though you know
black one a couple moves things like
that so slow seems everything is ok and
sometimes when you consider moves like
what I just did moving the bishop back
giving black time I mean what if they
what if they counter attack what if they
use that development advantage would use
this time well that can happen in
specific cases but again most of the
time if they want to open up the
position which is consistent with
attacking or using that time in using
that development advantage the ensuing
positions are also going to be favorable
for the bishops the bishops right now
don't have you
great diagonals but they have that
potential energy if black wants to
really attack black black wants to
attack white because I'm kind of like
still shuffling my pieces around then
it's also going to improve my pieces and
I'm not I'm not particularly worried
about that I'm going to face that
position whenever rises but it's also
going to strengthen my bishops when he
pushes his bonds or gives some targets
because there aren't any targets black
also has a good pawn structure right now
so yeah it doesn't concern me too much
taking time to tuck them away Queen d7
pretty pretty standard he wants to play
rook da there's not any I don't know not
too many other squares there a lot of
options out of options here but no
obvious breaks for black so black you
might be waiting for me as well I mean
d5 d5 doesn't work because I can just
take an e5 is hanging at five doesn't
work because I have you know although
I'm attacking it twice so yeah you know
there's nothing nothing nothing obvious
with your side yet but for me as both
sides want to complete the development
so I assume that involves now bringing
in the rooks but but my focus was still
you know I'm gonna the reason the reason
I believe that I mean if this position
is better for white it's not like it's
slightly better but it is a serious like
small advantage a long-term advantage
it's because of those bishops on D 2 and
C 2 so let's see how how to play with
these guys Queen d7 maybe in the future
f5 might be in the cards because
especially with some pressure on f2 and
rook here my queen being in this
position maybe there could be tactics
working so I have to keep that in check
I played Knight f5 here Netta 5 here who
is specifically works in this type of
position but besides 9 of 5 there are
some very standard moves that you do
here Harper would be would be a good
alternative
from Knight a5 rook a to d1 exactly rook
a to d1 is maybe the most natural move
Knight f5 requires
Galatian work 81 and how would you
follow that up
d4 yeah mm-hmm that's good so okay yeah
you want out of five yeah there's
there's this and it is we got the
suggestion here of playing Bishop c1 and
then maybe playing king h1 and there's
some things like that these moves yeah
these are all good moves for white and
they all retain that that advantage like
you're you're in the driver's seat here
so just discussing good moves to play in
these two Bishop middle games no need to
rush d4 moves that really don't come no
moves that really are bad or Camillo
moves or moves that you know give long
term weaknesses and long-term targets
the number one thing is really keeping
that flexibility in position keeping
those options open
then our bishops don't get tied down to
anything so yeah I mean moves okay
specifically here c4 would never be
played because of the night jumping to
d4 but if that night wasn't on e6 still
move like c4 even if it was attacking
something I would really be weary of
just because it permanently really gives
up d4 square so I'm just looking for
flexible moves in this case Knight f5
works I did that but the rook 81 pulling
the bishop back to clear out that file
also good some nodoz would be some no
no's in the position don't give up the
to don't keep don't--no reason to give
this up this might be a good diagonal
now compared to our bishop but we have
the suggestion from the audience
splitter it may be play by working it
king h1 and deal deal with it like that
but they work much better within two of
them together the two bishops so I
wouldn't not not not consider that at
all so net at five I did specifically
here it stops at five but it's you know
it works there is some future some
future ideas with this but I didn't need
to do that to continue playing the type
of game I wanted to
which was to sit back get my rooks get
all the pieces ready and then at the
right time go for the breakthrough but I
mean black black and just only only
sitting wait really
there's no easy opening there's no
really easy way for him to stop me from
doing that and I'd be happy with any
suggestions for black would be happy to
look at here
rook 88 natural a4 they need to move it
like it didn't need to make a move like
a four could have continued work 81 I
had some ideas of potentially like a
four may be gaining some space with a
five and B 4 because that still keeps
all the squares covered a5 and B 4 isn't
this isn't really a permanent weakness
it still keeps most of the center
squares and they're being covered but
yeah I wasn't I I wasn't exactly sure
about this move but it's a type of
position where you don't have to play
only one move for it like there are a
lot of good moves and you don't it's not
about finding that precise perfect move
you retain your advantage by keeping by
just not by just not offering targets
and and having your bishops passive so
a4 is playable a3 is playable all these
moves 84-83
there's a few ideas here rook 81 they're
all playable black is still not
threatened threatening d5 but a4 I did
have an idea maybe play a 5 maybe play a
5 and future kick that Bishop off of the
diagonal it seems you know makes a
little bit of sense because then I don't
have to worry about that counter play an
F 2 but there are other ways to deal
with it as well which which is a which
is why I mean I like talking about these
positions there's there's multiple
answers and you don't always get that in
chess in six rook 81 so I'm not even
sure about that trade-off but a4 is not
really a target it's on that light
square bishop gotta protect it why do
you play a6 if I play a 5 Bishop a 7
well that's that's that's definitely so
you're asking yeah
why six I tend to agree with that maybe
like Bishop z71 go but at this point
maybe was undecided he can still play
Bishop c7 anyways it would have season
move if you did it so after after a 6 we
have rook 81 I could have done that
first just to double-check guys man yeah
so night at 5:00 yeah native 5 just just
so we're on the same page I am playing
the tape with a pawn in to play f6 not
with the Queen but with the pawn in play
f6 it's just a very attractive option of
messing up black's pawn structure just
just to clarify that rook 81 king h it
you didn't seem to be particularly
uncomfortable disposition now now King
h8 these all the moves we played this
game have been news people could kind of
find relatively fast aren't you haven't
been playing tactical moves not much
calculation required King h8 not a
natural move but it's a waiting move and
maybe gets the King off of some things
that in my mind probably he wants to
move his king maybe here maybe so I
never ever have some sort of diagonal
threats if you tries to go for f5 at
some point or open things up maybe maybe
that's one of the things and I haven't I
haven't forced an issue yet so black
black is also kind of waiting for white
to open up the position because but
there aren't too many attractive ways
for black to take advantage of this the
the waiting game
so I played Bishop c1 I mean just again
without it without it without really
thinking Bishop c1 with the bishops just
just wait wait for some something to
happen if not solely solely I kind of
like work towards a strategical goal of
black which is going to turtle then you
have to force it at some point but at
least you have the time to pull your
pieces on optimal squares and then open
up the position if blacks not going to
do anything I'm going to take the time
for my bishops back like this and try to
clear out the field so I mean if I had
if you just if you just shuffle back and
forth because there aren't unless you
guys have some suggestions for black
there are
too many to me I might I'm going to
eventually try to go for D for D for be
ideal to open up in the center that's
that's usually great for the bishops you
open up the center open open up both
sides of the board that they're pretty
effective like that but if you weren't
to do that I might again just you know
try to provoke some weaknesses here h4
h5 but d4 should be at some point
achievable maybe because I'm like b3
Bishop b2 d4 so I I don't have great
suggestions here what he did might have
been okay I do have a suggestion would
happen the game he does g6 g 6g 6 is
similar to night g8 similar ideas there
it does weaken some of the dark squares
but black does have control of a lot of
dark squares right now has is d4 f4 g5
he's controlling the 96 is a good piece
I mean it's one of those position box
pieces aren't necessarily bad I mean in
relation to wipe the only difference is
Bishop c2 bishop c1 against the two
knights on g7 and u6 but besides that a
lot of things are relatively equal or
symmetrical it was g6 and things could
get good for good for black as well
there's some lines for example if I have
to move this Knight let's say queenie
797 Queen d7 now it looks like d4 is
really quite hard to achieve with a net
on your six Bishop Bishop on B 696 it
looks hard to achieve d4 I'm probably
I'm going to have to give up on that
idea and try to slow play and open up
the position through another Avenue
whether that be again maybe
maybe first playing b4 a5 Bishop a6 just
to show that actually I'll even show
that I'll play b4 let's say you give me
a move
maybe maybe try to try to you know gain
space like that and okay maybe there's a
bit of risk like this as I say it's best
to have the pawns flexible but you know
if I've tried hard and nothing's
available something like that this is
still at least not you know really
accessible for black yet there was some
it's pretty good yep yeah you might you
might want to do that I wasn't sure
going to play d5 but yeah I mean that's
why that's why you played g6 okay that
says I'm like here yep that's that's
probably the case and and then I meant
have to I might have to be looking at
giving up the bishop pair with Bishop e3
and trying to play for middle game
Bishop against Knight but the one
benefit let's say something like this
the one benefit I don't like giving up
the bishop there is at least we fixed
some pawns in the color of our Bishop so
something like this would also be a
bishop against Knight not the same but
if black was to do this type of attack
could probably probably again favors
favors white and he's sort of opening up
the of the position and then and then
maybe you know something you for d5 next
it should objectively favor white with
all the pawns on that color but but as I
say the position is not it's worse for
black but it's not more than that so
it's yeah just just trying to play the
bishops the best way they can and and
the black plays well you play as well
but a lot of mistakes can be can be
forced almost so yeah he plays g6 and 97
yeah there's nine take c7 if I I
actually didn't see g6 fully I saw it
but it's not the prettiest move
weakening those are sirs but as I saw
right away 97 is not what I wanted to do
9 h6 move like f5 is very scary but not
only is 6
be good but it also looks like it could
definitely got stuck in FIV f5 is uh it
looks like here white was being too
fancy to slow with those bishops and
black is ahead he has some real tactical
counterplay that doesn't you know well
I'm not really going to get to realize
my bishop advantage the F takes F takes
e4 is coming so but there is something
better better for for white than than
these options which often happens when
the position gets sharp because now
black is lashing out he's not waiting
around and waiting for me to play d4 he
plays something g6 it's double edge it
looks pretty safe but you know this is
also opening up the position also often
helps helps helps the bishop side as I
was saying so even though I did not
really prepare for you for g6
intuitively I knew to also look for four
ways that this could benefit me like
that my bishops can can can benefit from
from this so any any suggestions for
white here yeah yeah 9999 96 what's
actually even scary about a move like
ninety six okay I'm playing one thing
I'll say I'm playing a low-rated player
they're willing to attack and cut take
risks maybe maybe he'll take back maybe
you might just play a five and I don't
know just just open up that F file and
not allow that like it's a lot of these
lines are pretty scared looking looking
from f5 and maybe just ignore it I don't
know but it even looks hmm take
that's rude yeah III just yeah that
maybe you do that by 96 96 Queen d6
check yeah this this this is a
interesting idea but I think probably
black will even just give up some
material to stop the attack now that is
up a piece although that's probably has
to do something like 98 but he does have
a piece up and then maybe Queen e7
something like that but it's an
interesting idea there's something even
yeah it's worth looking there's
something else there's something else
bishops bishops open position
and I can see it planted without
calculation
I just D for D for yer that's almost
another move yes there's a piece hanging
but black like to just play g6 he's
ready to open up the position then I'm
also gonna be ready as well so so that
but as I said usually usually when when
black goes for white also we'll have
have some counter chances as a result so
d4 and yeah it looks it looks a bit
crazy at first but just a quick the
initial calculations everyone's going to
be like okay I'll just going to take the
material that's a critical line that
Knight has almost nowhere to go and if
we're just clearing out if we're trading
material if we're trading pawns then we
are helping helping the bishops for the
most part unless there's some some bad
tactics going on just just the basic one
one four one trades are going to be good
for these guys here so after this
position were threatening recapture
material among other things but what the
process that led me to even consider
consider that as a candidate move was
with some of those general principles he
actually took which okay you know some
people do it wasn't it wasn't it's not
an immediate it's not immediate
compensation it's it's just the two
bishops and I get a bunch of pawns if I
was playing and calculated thoroughly I
probably would play that six that's the
best move objectively and then we have a
position like this now I mean because
one of the reasons why this is so
powerful is I have f6 next move which
which really gives the special MC to a
lot of power but d4 you realizes Oh
White has this tactical idea I'd play f6
and we'd have a position like this and
this is also a good position to just
look at from that simplistic bishop
point of view two bishops Ian's Bishop
Knight net I would have to now do 97 I
have to do 97 because the knight is now
hanging on on f5 I don't have f6 to
follow up afterwards and they have night
90 G 597 27 and we have still a fairly
symmetrical position like this where
black hasn't made so many bad moves or
anything it's still pretty pretty
straightforward white still has that
edge but you know black black black
wasn't what wasn't dead or anything they
need to go for this in a position like
this I would probably just you know
Bishop h6 or Bishop e3 and the game
would go like that and you know maybe
try to now now at least have the chief
d4 try to open up the position and and
that's a better position for white it's
still it's still a game but we've
achieved something now
at least one step at a time but it would
have still been a game he didn't have to
go for but it wasn't immediately obvious
I guess to him what was the situation
and because when you play move like g6
you don't expect that white can just
leave the night there otherwise no
reason to play g6 maybe I have six first
or Knight g8 or some other moves I
suggested so g 6d for G takes f five I
take and he does Knight takes d4 now he
realized that things are not he looking
I guess not he didn't play perfect but
he realized now that the sacrifice is
pretty sound there was no real good way
to give back back the material his
bishop diagonal is blocked so I mean you
know something like f6 this type of
position yeah it's not losing but now we
have some more in balance now we have
white got those bishops open you know
play the play move out moves out Queen
h5 it's that little question
yep exactly yeah yeah you can take a
look give any suggestions he probably
wanted to leave the net on e6 because at
least when white recaptures black can
recapture and my queen is hit on f3 but
it it's hard to find some good weighting
moose current material counted is the
piece for a pawn but yeah there's no way
to really save the piece without risking
getting me yeah there's not like you can
make a move I'll probably just follow up
with Queen h5 black black is worse here
is not that it does Knight takes d4
though which does allow for something
nice the reason he does Knight takes d4
is at least you have material so he
doesn't have a piece but he now gets two
pawns so material count is up a pawn for
black but it allows a pretty pretty nice
finish f6 now have to otherwise black
will play f6 and just block that Bishop
Knight g6 Queen h5 d5 few different
moves here but what I was really
planning myself was rookie four and
we're cage for with unstoppable
checkmate you can't play something like
cleaning 6 because the roti 4 okay it
doesn't matter I'll just show the finish
because I didn't want to show something
else as well
so there's no ways Rickey for a rock
edge four there's also rook t4 right now
so d5 you played to stop that but rook
takes d4 he takes d4 Rick here and
Bishop takes g6 no matter what next move
you can't take back with H pawn because
it's you know pinned and you can't take
back with the F pawn physical then my
queen
rook hit h7 so that was how the game
ended I don't think that finish yeah I
mean that's just nice to show but the
moves are led to it we're pretty
standard I didn't have to spend too much
time this game actually because I have
been I had been you know playing quite a
bit in the Sopot I did quite a bit of
experience playing a step in middle game
with the two bishops against Bishop a
knight in a fairly symmetrical structure
so yeah it's just just materially
winning so yeah that's an example some
baby moves but now now I have another
position to show and see I'm going to
probably ask a few more questions about
some good moves some things to do and
things not to do in this type of middle
game that was the players black was an
FM by the way in case anyone was
wondering this was a gonna fast forward
to the middle game here this was a game
but last year white is a
mvl black is Geary it's a happens to be
happens to be a Berlin it's not a
coincidence that a lot of players don't
enter the Berlin defense because we're
all uncomfortable playing against two
bishops just fundamentally it's just
uncomfortable for so mostly for players
and in this case MDL is white this is a
sideline just like I avoided the end
game is we're just uncomfortable giving
that is fundamentally the case and this
is this is the position right off the
bat from the opening not too theoretical
and it's defined almost the same way
I mean blacks position doesn't look bad
I play this as black drawing games
whatever and position the objectively is
is is okay but it's preferable for white
slightly and there's a it's a pretty
nice display why first question d4 or d3
if we're going to move the D pawn kind
of you know think a bit about the last
game and how just discussed pawn
structures basic pawn moves things like
that
d4 looks pretty nice too it's not really
an ugly-looking move so it's not the
easiest question but we also have d3 as
an option or any other suggestions as
well
until it's white to move here and we do
have to develop a little bit well the
move is d3 and computer won't tell you
that but every single Grandmaster plays
plays d3 even if the even though the
computer might say d4 that that's that
still shows a little bit of how you know
the line of thinking is a little bit
different
d3 gives black less targets you've got
that darts for Bishop it just leave some
more possibilities open we can play d4
if we want to later
so d3 dot that's that's what people do
that's what I would do as well keeping
that flexible pawn pawn structure maybe
at some me because you know we have two
bishops maybe you want to play c4 leaves
the pawn structure flexible and
undefined for the time being we can play
d4 if we want to if they stop us from
playing d4 and they played you for
themselves then okay that's also there's
a consequence there to that that
potentially some negative effects for
black to that maybe gives us more space
but it definitely opens up the position
a little bit and gives us more targets
by by putting it up on on d4 so no it's
not worried about that you can do that
as black you can do whatever so f5 again
f5 so f4 is actually an idea here from
for black so just play up for when do
the bishops kind of get trounced or
sometimes you know get in trouble is
when tactically when the attack comes
like just positionally usually you're
safe but if you'd be too slow be too
careful sometimes you know black or
whatever has the night nights or Knight
and Bishop they they get in time so a
couple moves here for white g3 or at
four which is preferable you consistent
with this type of line of thinking yeah
based on previous
yeah okay that's that's a that's a
that's a good answer
you said based on previous play g3 but
f4 you kind of like to stop at four but
based on what I've been saying g3 but f4
could definitely be considered here g3
was played why because why not worry
about f4 move like Bishop h3 and at
least you know every single pawn move
every single pawn move every single
attacking move you know they do against
the two bishops does free up some space
for the bishops for the most part and
this is an example it's not like change
changes the position entirely but it
does give that Bishop some scope and he
wasn't worried about it so I mean but
they both could have been justified but
g3 is more flexible and and white white
in this case he's a he's a very strong
player he's not really worried about
potential threats it see if there's no
actual threat he's going to play the
more more positional more standard move
and g3 and leave some options open and
now and now and now if this actually
this didn't happen if this actually
happened
I assumed he would just resume
development and not really worry about
this point I have for for the time being
but yeah at least the bishop on h3 is
pretty good
so anyways g3 was played Queen f6 so if
you're playing g3 you probably not
playing out for you would have played
out for in one go you're going to
develop it's going to develop as white
when you have the two bishops you want
to be too ambitious where's that Bishop
going d4 sorry f4 g5 III or d2 if you
have to pick a square
I'm not speaking about like some sort of
deep calculation for the most part just
just in general do you need to put the
bishops far out to be developing them
yeah you'd rather have your Bishop on d2
yep rook recovers the file no reason to
block that and the bishops don't need to
be just because of you know further down
the board doesn't mean they're
necessarily more effective
baby baby moves baby moves guys this
should be - yeah and I agree with all
these moves I really liked this game
Bishop d2 and you know we're going to
see some similarities all across the
board here with how to play so black
still does not really many weaknesses f5
is maybe a bit of ambitious move but
he'd at least he keeps some tactical
threats 96 yep yeah so ok this is this
is unlike the last game there was a bit
of calculation probably required here
clean me too he probably did spend a few
minutes calculating that night I have
spent a little bit of time looking at
myself clean B - what's whites
first of all yeah as I said you in
position opens up gets crazy usually the
bishops are okay but this is a pawn and
it could be even more than that rook b1
is the most natural move but yeah the
reason why specifically is route b1
now if you move back just trading pawn
for pawn we say is good for the bishops
right but that's not the case you're
right because you can take a second pawn
I assume that because otherwise I mean
rook B 1 should be assumed trading
trading pawns is good but let's say
Queen a - well happens to be that
tactics are available in this position
just like in the last position when
things got a little bit tactical what
can what can white do here
he just actually has sent us a visual C
3 there's bishops III just the Queen
gets a bit uncomfortable Bishop before
you move the rook anywhere and there's a
c4 move as far as I know c4 and the
Queen gets very uncomfortable
oh I think the Queen gets in some
trouble here I'm trying to remember
exactly the sequence but it starts out
with Bishop before rook here and sorry
sorry
I think c3 might be better the Queen
gets trapped there's a queen trap here
yeah yeah that's it that's it that's it
that's it there's a queen trap here
Queen here and c3 but almost all the
variation is like yeah I mean box Queen
is just getting hunted his pieces on the
board but yeah this is a queen trap so
it doesn't work
so yeah Bishop d2 but okay let's say it
did work if it did work for if it did
work for black this Queen takes B - and
we wanted to solve that how do the two
pawn moves available in the position to
block that devout c3 or d4 which one
would we do to stop yeah yeah we just do
c3 just they don't need oh yeah Oh C 3 C
3 would be d 4 might still seem very
natural to allow you guys just to take
that space those bishops don't need that
space right now it's more important to
just not have any targets for the other
side so C 3 if that was actually like
something to worry about Queen f6 Bishop
d2 Knight d6 and now a nice move very
standard in this type of position
started provoke a weakness if they don't
make a weakness themselves Bishop c3 and
and yeah I mean some people like Bishop
c3 he plays d4 he gains a tempo he gains
a tempo I just I just attacked and I get
the attack back so I just wasted a move
it's not that simple
every time the pawn pushes forward make
some more weaknesses for black I mean
now our Bishop definitely has
a bit more scope here has a bit more
space and not part on d4 I mean it's
space but let's say we just moved back
which is what he did without thinking
this was a very easy sequence there are
not still no targets for for black to to
attack even with this pawn on d4 yes it
helps control these if any of those
squares were weak it would be fantastic
but white is keeping a very flexible
setup so b2 and ff2 both cover those
squares so even if you've got a piece
you can't get a piece onto e3 or C 3 so
that d4 is just a weakness opening out
the position every pawn every pawn which
does have a pretty serious consequence
you could have also moved the Queen away
and that might have been a better move
to play Queen f7 but we got to move like
Bishop c3 might not come to some
people's mind but Bishop c3 yet that's
it that's a good move there's no rush
here yet d4 Bishop d2 now f4 is covered
knight f7 and now now I'll just quickly
say wipe does that for why because now
f4 is a threat f4 is a bit more scary
because f4 the night might come to gg5
there's some tactical reason so he
finally takes some time he makes a
mortal middle move f4 rook rook e8 so
far I don't know how you guys would
evaluate it it still seems to be roughly
equal it's like or it's like black just
played a bad opening because otherwise
black seems to have been playing pretty
straightforward no I mean I prefer white
but yeah it still still should doesn't
seem to learn anything particularly bad
or at least it'd be pretty scary if it
was like d4 the reason why you lose the
game so Bishop g2 now that d4 has been
played rook takes yet also possible but
you can do that next move no reason to
give up the file Knight d6 a3 I mean I
can't even explain them of like a
through what I can say is literally you
have the time to do that at least that's
not like a risky committal move
a3 I probably would prefer a for like at
the last game and that might even be
objectively better but you have that
safety net yes
that's that that's honestly a good
question why why a threesome is a queen
f1 maybe that is slightly more accurate
but you know there's that there's no
targets for blacks so White has really
enjoying his position queen f1 I like or
a for I like is why for can probably be
be thrown because we definitely see some
ideas that we might want to open up this
diagonal maybe make some threats push up
on 86 but Queen f1 Queen f1 seems good I
honestly can't answer a3 fully but what
I can say is a3 is not a bad note in
position doesn't change the nature of it
doesn't give any permanent weaknesses
and it's totally playable so it's nice
to have a position where you can play a
move like a three it's not rocket sound
like it's just it's okay at least it's
okay it's b3 b3 that that would be a
no-no right b3 guys we think we can at
least see night before and that is that
type of like permanent type of darks for
weakness that's not flexible a3 is still
flexible there's nothing nothing too bad
about that but yeah I would have maybe
preferred queen up one or a4 but you
have that flexibility you have that
flexibility that's keyword so a 3-bit
should be six he's moving around yes you
could trade but all this all this we'll
see what happens this would be six you
could have taken on you two but it
almost turns in the same thing there
should be six I mean maybe it's
connected to some sort of Bishop before
ideas I don't know by a three but
anyways Bishop e6 rook e8 rook e8 Queen
f1 and more pieces trade off the better
so everything is just on the e-file rook
e8 Ricky a queen f1 I'm just going to
play Rick u1 next move that's his idea
and just play this position why is he so
happy playing this position because
there's no targets for black so you can
play for white with no risk and and you
know at the back of your mind you know
and game to bishops I can't be doing bad
especially especially with with a pretty
good Bishop on g2 right now the bishop
on d2 isn't fantastic but it'll come
there's no rush there's definitely no
sense of urgency the way White's playing
King g8 rook e1 none of these moves
could have could have been stopped
riki six not giving up the file a four
so I'm again I mean I won't go too deep
into it but you can play move like a
four I would have done in one go but you
could still do so you could also take on
take on e6 to all possible but is he's
not making he's not doing anything rash
yeah like so
a4 a6 they should have three fish about
three is is in line with the next move
which is a bit deeper I'll I'll operate
that way some of the moves have been
easy this is sure a bit deeper yeah Kim
G - Kim G to make that's one idea bit of
G to the play King G - he's preparing
for the endgame there are other moves
here as well and they still actually
keep this advantage for white picture
Kim G - next move he actually had an
even ice nice idea on top of that even
different than I saw g6 King G - King f7
rook takes c6 Queen takes a6 Queen a1 so
that's that's a nice finish to this
whole sequence but everything up until
this point was all standard that I
believe everybody could pretty much
replicate the same same moves as as you
know a top 10 player without because if
they're not calculation based or really
deep ideas so and now he does Queen a1
and that show that you kind of knew this
long-term plan from a long time ago and
that's that's the very impressive part
that this evaluated everything right and
this it's because sometimes you're not
sure if you want to trade off and you
might not they might have a blocky the
endgame might not be winning it's not
clear it's winning but you have no risk
in your pushing here and you'll see so
I'll just show why but this whole
sequence is almost where pretty much
enough for me to show like I'm not
showing why they won the game of showing
how they got the advantage the type of
mission moves you're looking to make to
keep that that small but long-term edge
and put yourself in the best position to
either enter the endgame if you decide
to continue
the middlegame and try to make things
happen but it is the type of there you
see pretty much the entire entire
positioning of the pieces is kind of
based off of those two bishops and the
flexibility it allows so I mean it is
does win this game and I'll go through
that I don't need to explain and I'll
play through it very quickly but you
will see a lot of the same type of moves
a three or moving the bishop back to
near at starting square and trying to
provoke weaknesses don't give any
weaknesses but the with the bishops you
have yeah we see that's quite
uncomfortable play against them if they
don't give you any targets so I'll just
show Bishop c5 b for now it's time to
open it up he does it he was going to
play before anyways they should be 1
this is f 2 d 4 d 4 is probably the the
biggest mistake of the game yeah slow
moves b5 finally finally some tactics
Queen eight and now the reason why it's
better is yeah really this Bishop
dominates this night all the pawns on
the right color because you can't play
Knight d6 to defend everything because
you have Bishop d5 so oK we've opened up
the position entirely now even material
but now now it's just entirely open
bishop on f2 is the worst piece but
we'll see what happens
check some few annoying checks but yeah
you don't need to play super precise he
hasn't had to play perfect every single
move just retain the retain the
advantage and that all deals with how
how to deal with the pawn structure how
to play that so you know they shuffled a
bit but it was never it was never a draw
never clear draw g4 finally another
breakthrough waiting you know typical GM
games like
that finally awaiting because black
isn't blundering black is pretty much
playing as good as possible for their
circumstances and then but more pieces
to get rid off should favor unless it's
an actual complete draw but if it's not
actually a draw having tension in the
position and an open lines is going to
be good so Queen c4 they shelled around
and finally he was done shuffling around
he actually calculated that just this
endgame even though it's even material
is was like winning causes the pawn on
d4 and b4
so I'll just show how that happened now
Bishop f6 the knight is dominated by the
patient there are no targets for black
that's that's that's still the same
issue you'll use you beasts and did he
resign here
he played Knight take c2 and resigned
and he resigned now but yeah that's that
was the end of the game all and
hopefully those were a couple couple
examples of of playing pretty
symmetrical positions but having the
bishop pair